[Music]
welcome to the eviction 2022.
over the next few weeks you're going to
have a series of very intense property
investment challenges and the winner is
going to be given 20 000 pounds cash
prize to help kick-start your property
investment Journey
with the help of various mentors that
are going to be assisting me throughout
these challenges I'll decide who stays
and who gets evicted
because you needed to be spoon-fed wow
just don't lie to me don't call me alive
I'm not gonna lie down and take it
can I have a break
about the Coronation Street isn't it
you're evicted
[Music]
welcome back to the eviction this is the
semi-finals now so this is going to be
the last challenge before the final and
the final is going to be where I decide
who is the most worthy and who's going
to be the winner of 2022 eviction and
you're going to be given 20 000 pounds
Hard Cash to invest well in property she
need three things you're going to need
Sweat Equity great determination and a
work ethic which I believe all four of
you've got second thing is you need
knowledge you need knowledge to be able
to stack a deal you need knowledge to be
able to work out return on investment
how to speak to people the third thing
that you need to grow a property
business is you do need money you need
Finance so the deal that you found in
the last challenge both team you found
great deals you're going to be finding
the finance to fund that deal for each
of you found you're going to go out
there you're going to find an angel
investor or a business partner
that can fund the deal some of the
finance can be bridged in finance but
you're going to need some cash so really
you're gonna need a financial partner a
backer now the partnership can look like
whatever you negotiate you can give the
partner 50 of the profits you can give
them 60 of the profits for it doesn't
matter it's whatever you agree but so
your challenge today is to speak to as
many people that you know speak to your
family speak to your friends anyone that
you even think might have money that
might be interested in partnering with
you on a deal the winner will be the
person that raises the most money and it
gets a contract drawn up and signed
tonight by 9 30 pm
you need a lot of cash and you've got a
very short time so
[Music]
we need to raise 544
000 pounds 400 by the end of today I've
got something that might be of interest
to you two six bed hmos three thirds of
150 000 your gdv is 1.7 million on the
property the other need to rest 300 300.
hi Andy how are you
I'm all right I'm all right you get to
talk at the minute
brilliant how's your son
would you want to have a meet up and we
can you know get something discussed it
would be amazing to win the 20 000
pounds this is the year that I'm going
to change my life and I'm going to learn
as much as I possibly can and I'm gonna
throw myself 100 into every opportunity
I'm just gonna bring it into my
management company in Reading see if
you've got anyone who's looking to
expand
so
oh reception hi yeah sorry uh reception
is really bad can you hear me
foreign hello
hello can you hear me Andy
oh
we are if I have to go alone I can
probably do like up to 200 000 I can do
you could do 200k right
invested everything I've got right now
into property and there's not another
answer for me
so I now feel to put money into uh deals
okay
the way it's structured at the moment
you'll be able to pull all your money
about out so within the next six to
eight months
so one there's a plan go Plus
[Music]
easy monster too
next one
[Music]
yeah I'm Tony crook so I consider myself
a joint venture specialist tonight it's
going to be interesting it's a quite
simple task that all they need is a is
an agreed heads of terms and proof of
funds from the investor okay may sound
simple but you know it could be as
difficult as they make it I've been
watching them a little bit today they're
think they're spending a lot of time on
the phone maybe not enough time actually
speaking to people so let's see what
happens
So Yesterday guys I saw you in front of
200 people pitching this this you know
and you gave him a good a very good
pitch so how many of those people have
you approached and how many people are
interested not in that room no why so we
need to do that now why are you trying
to resell something where you actually
pitched it and you guys got Standing
Ovation people in that room could have a
lot of money or they may be flat broke
yeah but either way they are in the the
game of property investing yeah so
they're like-minded people they're the
first people you should be approaching
and you've already been pitching to them
I've never noticed you guys have been on
the phone throughout the days and things
that that presumably means you're not
phoning somebody in the room you're
phoning somebody out there get in the
room and you have to explain to them you
have some Pat Uh packs to them and
things like that when they've already
said it oh well let's go and get a mic
and get in there should we
go get it guys if you want to make this
happen you got to do it go for it
there's not that much people
my friends are described me as quite uh
comical sometimes a bit mischievous as
you all know we pitched here yesterday a
bit of an investment that we've got
going on at the moment I'd just like to
put out there that me and Adriana at the
moment we've actually opened the floor
on this investment so you all heard the
deal yesterday so we're opening the
floor now on this investment so if
anyone's absolutely really interested in
getting going and investing in property
such as hmos anyone interested in
Reading come and find us we'll happily
sit down have a discussion where and
we'll start talking about some money and
start making awesome money in this game
all right cheers everyone
Oh yeah double sketch clap
so I've um self-employed Builder I've
previously spent four years in the
parachute regiment which had to leave
because at an injury I mean my hip I
applied for the eviction to try and push
myself so I thought it's time to put put
the lessons that I've been lessons I've
learned into practice and really push my
abilities for me to win 20 000 pounds it
would mean an absolutely massive deal it
really catapult me up to different
levels a much greater speed than I
originally could have done bringing
other people up with me like my really
close family and friends people have
supported me through everything I've
ever done so whenever I had to be
discharged in the Army through medical
reasons people have been there to
support me through that who who've
supported me through every single
decision I've ever made they've never
once let me down with with the property
I can really give them a really good
existence I believe you can't help
anyone if you want to until you've
helped yourself like you can't you can't
go and do charitable work if you've got
enough funds behind you or anything like
that so a big Legacy that I would love
is for people who are being discharged
through uh from the military medically
I'd love to be able to support support
them through either injuries or
suffering from like PTSD or anything
like that to support them sort of guys
that'd be great
[Music]
so I mean we spoke earlier about how
we're going to approach this with
investors the the deal although it's an
all money out deal by the time we paid
the fees on the bridging there's not
going to be enough in that to be giving
them a return on investment is there
that's 25 so they'll be entitled to 25
so depending on what the portion they
put in that's the percentage
that they would be entitled to in the
capital appreciation their import
divided by total investment
yeah the numbers game you know with the
brrs and things like that working out
the mass although I'm not I wouldn't
ever say I'm bad at maths but some of
the numbers might trip me up a little
bit so I just got to make sure I'm sharp
on that we just need to be clear on how
we're going to approach I suppose I feel
like first for me each investor needs
the same pitch if we've got four or five
different investors they're going to be
getting a smaller and smaller car aren't
they a really ideally would like one
investor so should I just say to him
yeah because then we both done one and
then save both of our asses yeah exactly
if we say in 320 so we're looking for
160 each
here we're going there we're gonna how
are we gonna fight this out no we're not
listen we're not trying to fight this
[ __ ] dude Adam listen we're not
trying to fight this round we're gonna
win this round
two people
we're not we're not looking horns right
now do you understand I don't like the
way they're even like making us compete
amongst each other let's not think about
that right now Adam honestly we think
about winning and that's it yeah the end
bit like let's not worry about that it's
inevitable but let's not worry about
that yeah we need to be a team we need
to be strong we need to get through so
you're going to try and raise 160 000
yeah to make it easier we could just go
with one
do you know I mean the two biggest yeah
do you know what I mean yeah but this is
what I need to talk to you about because
we need to fully understand when we're
talking to these people because I've
sort of warmed them up but I haven't
done the thing yet I don't want to ring
and then be fumbling on what I'm saying
yes um
yeah
one seven
work out a fifth of that and then like
80 of it
so 100k
what percentage of the property do I own
versus what we can discuss
10 minutes is that all right all right
top mum thank you give us 10 minutes
dude which is a fifth of this 20 so it's
108
000.
[Music]
wait so if we if they wanted
five four four five
out of the get rid of that Purge oh the
five four four that we need
yeah
which
[Music]
yeah what do you want after that
that's a that's 100 return
[Music]
what was it what percentage of property
would you be happy with
[Music]
wait
it normally like 10 10 return on it
right should we do some one of them
we're welcomed we will we will come to
an agreement but we need we need to make
sure we're all on Level Playing Field
we'll have we'll do some more numbers
and we'll call you back it's as if
you're in the boardroom cheers
[Music]
I mean we'll we'll come up with
something we'll figure something out I'm
sure just yeah it's nearly four o'clock
in the day so
[Music]
right okay what's going on what's
Happening potentially got 100K so far
okay yeah and then he wants to pull his
money back out of a hundred thousand
pounds okay once pulling out the hundred
thousand pounds he wants to retain a
share in the actual Equity of the
property to benefit from the capital
appreciation and the cash flow and the
cash flow development and the
development he wants to much done it
wants too much yeah
and what if he can't pull all his money
out if he can't pull those money out
yeah what if it gets undervalued well
we'll have a guarantee a lower
percentage so we'll offer a certain
amount we'll guarantee something else
yeah so he needs to be aware of that
yeah he's putting the money in and then
it'll be a percentage of what gets
revalued for that he'll be able to pull
back out again yeah yeah I think you
guys need to be clear to him is he
confused
because I'm a little bit confused so is
he confused about what the actual deal
is
we've run through with the deal with him
again yeah and he understands what it is
the numbers the numbers are clear how
much are cash flowing what we're pulling
out what we're putting in what we expect
the capital appreciation to be
um so they should be pretty clear to him
rightly yeah so he's putting 17 of of
the value in yeah he gets 17 of the
refinance and you get 17 of the ongoing
profits
okay make it simple guys don't you
you're over confusing it sounds to me
that your your investors are leading you
rather than you leading your investors
you need to tell the investor and
educate the investor well this is what
we're offering we're offering plan a or
Plan B
yeah and if they don't like it then
thank you very much move on to the next
now you've got to become a little bit
more serious put a little bit more
urgency in it because you got to say
well you know if if you this deal will
go yeah I'm in agreement from you in
principle by 5 PM 3 P.M or whatever
because if you don't start leading this
comments this this deal guys we're
running out of time
foreign
[Music]
of course
I need to go and run this by Tony let me
go get Tony
[Music]
so I'm Sue gray my preferred thing to do
is be our I absolutely love it I want to
see that they've they know their deal
inside out that their figures are firm
it's no good just like guessing the
price the refurb or just asking one
Builder you know I want to see that
they've really firmed up their deal
because at the end of the day it's the
numbers game if the numbers don't work
people won't be interested I want to see
them having confidence to go and
approach people I want to see them
thinking outside the box who they can
approach
hey oh yeah you're right yeah I'm good
how's it going yeah it's good it's going
good we're going to be doing uh bridging
so we've worked out that we need 312
000. we're going to need to get as
bigger investors as possible we don't
want drip and drab investors because the
money's not there to do it if I were you
though because the big thing for an
investor is what's the end value so how
concrete are you on the 130 do-up how do
you know that's not 200 like what's this
based on where's the proof of that I'm
helping you to make this deal firm to
look at you firm it up everywhere firm
and value firm and then when you're
talking to people they're not just going
to be like oh yeah right numbers numbers
why'd I'd go why do you know that why do
you know this how do you know that what
are you offering them let's talk about
the offer now if you tell them that
they're getting 80 percent and if they
ask that's 50k you will you need to also
say that you're getting 20 so I think if
it was me I'd spell that out everyone is
always suspicious when someone else
comes up with the terms yeah because
they might be like well if I'm getting
that what are you getting what are you
getting I want you for the sake of
winning go and Pitch this we've
basically broken down exactly what it is
that we're pitching to the investor
we've got it nice and neat clear and
simple I'm going to try and pitch that
now to some uh potential investors and
cherelle's going to draw up a heads of
terms on my computer thinking she's just
simplified it for me massively yeah this
is it yeah
yeah another day the challenge is today
what was it okay we sort it out
tomorrow's over do the PDF also I think
so just your head yeah
all right mate yeah good thanks
it's 320k investment for you within then
we're going to remortgage so the value
is lifted after the five five years
um then we're going to remortgage again
after five years
um
320k investment all money back after
first remortgage 80 of all rental profit
are going to take a small 20 percent
as for us doing everything looking after
it all and we're thinking of doing a
third each of the profits but what we're
going to actually do is give you 50 of
the profit after the remortgage we were
thinking about doing a third split but
we thought you know what we want to do
business with you in the future
be really good we offered you 50 of the
profit after the remortgage
sweet and simple
[Music]
I'll tied up to your money foreign
[Music]
ERS to invest in uh one of my deals so
I've got a house in Hounslow we're going
to go in and turn into a six bed luxury
HMO the N value is 1.1 mil so you as the
investor you'd get all your money back
you are a gem thank you you're a beast
thank you so much can't wait to see you
yeah all right all right bye bye bye
70k oh
it's kind of right yeah it's kind of
very stressful I know this guy's got
some money
and we'll take 20 should we do the
management we do the brr as well we do
everything so once you put your money in
all you can just get your money back
you don't have to do anything
you haven't even got the best bit you
have here no I haven't got it yet it's a
good deal in it do you think that's a
fair deal Tony the other mentor and I
know he's got some money he's a good
investor he's a big investor I'm going
to NAB him and I'm going to pitch the
hell out of him tone
can we have a sit down for a minute
yeah is that okay yeah I just want to
speak to you about um about this about
our investment okay is that okay yeah
we're looking at you getting all your
money back after the first three
mortgage then after that you'd get 80 of
all the rental profit for doing
absolutely nothing 88.0 80 hello Mr
crook how are you
guys doing
we are doing good we've got an amazing
deal on the table has Adam told you
about it I'd have to look at it
begin with I need to see how liquid I am
actually at this moment time anyway yeah
sure yeah
[Applause]
I just need an investor right
we know how much we need to raise for
this deal okay
five four four well now the problem
we've got is when we know we're casually
just over 50k a year and if we're off
offering Angel Investors
ten percent you'll get five Angel
Investors at 100 Grand that's his cash
flow swallowed up so we will be
literally left with a capital
appreciation after five years
you can't rely on that really can you so
it's just the best view of nothing yeah
it's the best the capital appreciation
that's it and what what's your capital
appreciation in that area it's going to
rock it with an article foreign
where would your headspace be at about
swallowing your cash flow from Angel
Investors I wouldn't like that
yeah me personally what's the point
you're doing you're doing all the work
no point in you guys doing it for
nothing but then the same thing is they
they need to be benefiting first so
what's their options what server what
what can you offer them can you offer
them a fixed return yeah or can you
offer them a a percentage return so it's
intimate with um Adriana is and Matt is
that they're sort of analyzing how much
they have to give the investors and
finding out there's not as much money in
the deal as they originally thought so
that's the real interesting thing when
you when you when you're starting off
pitching the deal without actually
finding out initially starting it from
where the funding comes from you you can
get yourself stacked but let's see you
know they've got a good deal they need
to need the right investor to um to
approach them now
you pitch got your pitch you're going to
go from stage and Pitch isn't it
[Music]
done okay
it's difficult ain't it I think you
probably have more luck in the lobby
yeah
so you think you're struggling because
you can't pull all the money out with
the investors
I've just been over there and um I've
been speaking to
um Matt and Adriana I think they're
struggling Matt seems quite stressed
yeah
um so we should relax because it's not
an all money out deal I think he's
struggling yeah with that with that
aspect of yeah how he's structuring it I
don't think it's overly appealing okay
to investors
I've I think we've got an invest that
I'll be able to get signed over so for
like half of it okay
um so what I'm saying is if I can mail
this
get that over the line we're good we're
all good come on man
uh no I'm just ringing about it um
brought to work tomorrow and ready I'm
trying if it's something that you might
be interested in the returns that we can
offer
no okay
[Music]
um I'm just wondering if you knew any
investors that are looking to JV I know
you can answer
yeah yeah build costs 150. come on
all right I hope it is cheers
you've got the capital appreciation of
course
we've got 500 Grand who wants to go stop
it stop it
so what we would be prepared to offer is
to go 50 50 so obviously we'd put the
Sweat Equity in but how we would
organize the deal is on refinance all
the money that sets pulled out will go
directly to you we're expecting 22 000
to be left in the deal but any money
that is left in the deal from your
initial investment you would get all of
the profits up until the point that
you're paid back so
after that then we would be 50 50
partners because your money would be
completely out of the deal and then
you'd receive 50 of the profit so that's
around two thousand pound profit every
month obviously the 50 of the capsule
appreciation 50 of the development at
the back of the property as well
you wouldn't okay what would you what
would what would work for you
you know we would be putting our time
and square Equity into the property
would you be happy to work on maybe 60
40 basis
[Music]
okay perfect and I'll call you back and
we'll have a talk in 20 minutes Perfect
all right thank you bye
he wants too much doesn't it wants too
much
yeah it sounds like it to me yeah well
it's like we're doctors jump on
something that's just [ __ ] but then we
need to have some money secured
so who have you tried anywhere else is
this your only chance
we give him 10
. we could always work his way up from
that yeah so what 20 of the gdv
what you're saying 20 off 20 of the full
shebang
20 is a lot do not think it's too much
guys clock's ticking yeah you guys
should have been having this bit of sort
out a long time ago yet you should you
don't know what you what you're offering
so how can you be attracting any
investors when you don't actually when
you're not clear about your offering get
them to sign in principal and let's move
because you've got you know you got a
few hours now
I'm trying to figure out a fair solution
for everyone involved
because what he is asking for is just
ridiculous
[Music]
I've got one person who wants to put
everything in but I need him to actually
sign the terms and conditions yeah let's
put everything in did he we've got
people but they just
slow people are slow but it's always
been for five hours
you know we're gonna
well they are good they are gonna we're
gonna have to it's Friday it's a Friday
night I don't think I deserve to go
because I don't think I was the weakest
link because at the end of the day I'm
the one that got the property deal I'm
the one that three hours before the task
nearly ended said look guys we still
haven't got a drill by following your
leads so now let's follow my lead we've
got this um it's a BRI HMO project
I think you were you saw at the pitch
yesterday yeah yeah so what we would aim
to do is get your money back to you
um after the first remortgage once it
was the value was uplifted and we'd get
that back to you within six to 12 months
and she did all your money back
yeah okay so your risk is gone then
isn't it yeah and that's it yeah yeah
we're gonna suggest is that you could
then take 80 of the profit the rental uh
profits
first five years
80 80 so we would take only a small 20
percent
to manage the property basically and
also it's about the investors we where
we want to raise Finance to do these
bigger projects we want to build trust
with our investors that when the next
one comes because we've now got that
experience you're happy so we want to
give you more to give you that
reassurance build that trust and build
that confidence in us as well okay but
what we're originally going to do is we
were going to do a three-way split on
the appreciation of the property yeah
um but because it's obviously it's our
first time if you're doing a business
with you you want to sort of like
shirelle said earlier we want to build
trust and we want to do more business
we'd actually want to give you 50 if
they appreciate of the capital
appreciation on top of your investment
altogether you will get these two
together
I mean how do you feel how do you feel
about it
sound good to you yeah
I mean have you got 160k to invest today
not too University so what we're looking
for today is yeah we've got heads of
Thames you know this it takes it's a
process doesn't it so today what we're
looking for is just that initial
commitment to say I do have funds and I
do like the sand that is still yeah
you know
[Music]
would you be willing to sign the head of
terms and move forward
yeah yeah my man
[Music]
nice one thank you very much
[Music]
the first of many
part of you
[Music]
thanks yeah yeah
guys can we answer them like five
minutes at the cameras just so we can
work through are we ready
[Music]
hi it's Adriana
[Music]
yeah we've not actually purchased a
property yet but yeah we've agreed to
the sale and got it off the market
we know we would be doing the restaurant
on the broad gym we wouldn't actually be
financing the deal
[Music]
[Music]
so we would be putting our time and
obviously Sweat Equity into the deal you
know like working with on the refurb and
managing the property after that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Express
so this investor has given up as
predicted
um you know they still got a few more
hours but to be honest with you I think
they've given up they've thrown the
talent already Hey guys you're right
what's happening my guy he said it's
just sit too with pressure because I
love you guys both yeah but you know to
let yourself down and let us down so I
mean that's to me that's instant
eviction
all right yeah
[Music]
lost
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the boardroom
semi-finals about to go through to the
finals and in this session at least two
of you will be evicted so Matt Adriana
give us a Lowdown about what happened so
we are we are quite a good start really
we managed to send some Fields auction
investors
uh we got a bit tripped up with not
knowing actually
understanding how much we was willing to
give out so we needed to regroup
actually started to get a bit of an
understanding what we were going to
offer investors and yeah we got when we
managed to get an investor that would
say they would put some money in that
one that was my investor our Journey's
got it on should probably tell you about
between him and his partner had 500 care
to invest unfortunately I just didn't
manage to get him over the line
um and and seal the deal with him
unfortunately I tried me hardest Adriana
what happened so I put The Feelers out I
actually got a phone call and it was
someone who wanted to who put me in
touch with a guy
um spoke to him on the phone we had a
really good report and went in asking
for what we needed to cover the bridge
in which was 544 000 pounds he actually
then said I would finance a full deal
and we got to negotiating we got down to
60 40 and that he would put all the
money in once he was then paid back out
so we had an arrangement once he was
paid back out on refinance and anything
further than that the profit would go to
him until we were clear it was a good
agreement he was happy with that and he
was going to put all the money in
however he didn't want to sign the
contract he said it was too short notice
not not knowing I was he kind of wanted
to you know discuss a bit more so I
understand that was the challenge I
didn't manage to get it over the line is
that still on the table it's still on
the line as to be an investor and yeah
but it didn't he didn't want to seal the
deal there and then here's the thing
right raising Finance is the most
important part to running a property
business it's the most important part if
you if you can find deals and if you can
furnish houses and all this stuff that's
all good you can't raise Finance can't
do the business that's that's it how did
you feel like on well I was very
disappointed guys to tell you the truth
I listened to your pitch the day before
and it sounded good sounded like you
guys had your head together but today
when I spoke to you you were confused
you didn't even know what the deal was
if you guys don't understand the deal
how the hell is an investor going to
understand the deal you guys came to me
and you didn't even know how to pitch to
an investor you didn't know what
percentages you were going to offer what
deals you're going to offer so I was
very disappointed in that
I said to you this morning doesn't
matter what the returns are what matters
is that it's clear if it's 60 40 got to
make it clear you've got to be able to
put something to an investor and say
this is what we want this is the deal
you have the deal you spent a lot of
time working on the deal previously and
the thing that really blows my mind is
my man Tony invests millions of pounds
into my deals Tony has made 100 million
pounds
and Tony was mentoring you did you ask
Tony if you wanted to put money in no
why didn't you ask Chinese when I put
money without a mentors not we didn't
see that that was option on the table
the other team did they didn't hold back
and I was your Mentor so that you know
they had the goal to come to me and say
Tony would you like to put money into
our deal why would you even ask Tony did
did you ask Sue no I didn't know
Tony said to me about an hour and a half
ago I'm still waiting I'm still waiting
Tony who's got seven figures in his bank
who's rooting for you and has been
specifically assigned to be your mentor
on this task because I know he's got
money
and you don't even ask the question you
know what we call that stupid
[Music]
how much do you raise 430
000 430 between the two yeah 500 000
together so you've got seventy seventy
thousand contract signed contract signed
I also had um other investors who were
willing to fine who who gave you that 70
grand I got that from an academy member
okay
and he's good for it he's good for it
yeah what about yourself how did you get
where'd you get the 470 from uh two
investors that I've known for a long
time and an academy member what made
them invest they trust me so you're
gonna buy the house we are we've got we
wouldn't get the builders survey we also
want to get some valuations done because
we've had
um one that's out of what it is that
we've projected I told you the valuation
was sketches yeah so that's why I told
you that I've told the um investors look
this is what we've got in the table
we've done it per square meter but we
are going to get it checked because
obviously we don't want to take your
money what did you think about having
gone
I thought they were really good actually
I think they needed a bit of firming up
around the figures yeah it was very
helpful yeah if that deal falls through
will the investors put that money into
your next deal are they good for it yeah
do you think it's an unrealistic
challenge to raise that kind of money in
a day and maybe not maybe not for
someone like yourself but I wouldn't say
it's unreal it's not unreal it's
achievable 100 but someone who's quite
new to raising Finance well I do know
over time I will be able to develop the
skill set to do that would you reckon I
think it's a bit of an unrealistic
challenge realistic life it was
definitely it was difficult
um I think in the time constraints it
was more that feeling the pressure on
investor obviously fair enough we didn't
utilize everything that was there but
the links we did have they were they
were really strong and I do believe that
we will be able to secure those links I
don't think you guys believe in your own
deal I think I believe in that they're
passionate up you didn't believe in it I
wish I'd have kept scottin
I think Scott would have raised the
money I think Scott at least would have
asked Tony
so how much did you actually raise how
much did you get contract signed
I mean at least 10 grand would have been
something at least oh we got something
nothing
if you were one of my staff
in a room with 200 investors with Tony
who's got over a million pounds in his
bank and after a day's work with one job
you just said nothing I'd fire you on
the spot not me being harsh maybe on TV
cameras I just feel like man let's get
out of here it's completely shocking
isn't it time yeah you'd be fired gone
not just me in any company
that's disappointed in that is I'm
bitterly disappointed
yesterday it was really difficult for me
because there were six people having to
evict two was really difficult today is
really easy Adriana you're evicted Matt
you're evicted
[Music]
[Music]
I've been a Victor but I feel I feel
good you know I'm up against a lot of
strong people in there uh ended there
I'm just I'm just a builder trying to
dim a bit in property so I'm proud about
what I've achieved already do I think it
would be fair that are evicted if it was
solely based on this challenge then yeah
best best or best on the full process I
thought I was one of the strongest
contenders but you're only as good as
your last performance yeah
it was um
really strong link when you're asking
someone for half a million pound within
the space of five hours you know he was
a greed in principle but he didn't sign
a contract so that's what that's what
tripped it up concentrated too much on
one one investor into it so with a time
constraint we we struggled but I think
if if we had a bit longer with them
investors
would have eventually come over the line
we would have got the deal sorted
I'm obviously got it to be evicted but
you know there's some really really
strong people in there going on from
this I'm just obviously going to take
everything on board and
and you know really try and make well
we'll make a success of myself
[Applause]
I knew you'd be here
I I've had some tough times in the
boardroom uh last couple of times but
today I really went for it I really
pulled it out of the bag I'm super proud
of myself and
um looks like I'm an eviction finalist
I made it to the finals like
that's overwhelming it's mind-blowing
very much Bittersweet
um the people that I was up against I
genuinely feel the friends of mine you
feel amazing because you've got this far
but then you feel like you can feel for
the other people that have lost
it's hard to contain the excitement for
the next challenge I'm I'm you know I'm
ready for it like to be in the final
again the best foot forward is going to
come that's all I've been doing being
myself being true to myself and trying
to push forward and it's just going to
happen again so I'm unsure of what's the
gun people have been talking about
business plans
I have in my head a very good idea of
how I would spend twenty thousand pounds
I don't know who's going to win they're
both amazing candidates both well within
their own right and
if I were to as a guest I'd say Cheryl
Cheryl's face she's a fierce fierce
Contender look I'm here to win you know
that's the goal and that's the vision
the fact that I'm going neck and neck
with her now is
I'm very proud of myself for that and
we've really had a conversation with
each other when we get in there look man
if we've got to be conductors and
throwing each other under the bus we get
it as long as it's not personal we're
not going to take it personal I'm gonna
bring it
we know what's coming we both got to
fight for it we're both beasts
um but we're just going to enjoy each
other's company until into a boardroom
[Music]
[Applause]
you are officially a finalist in the
eviction 2022 one of you is going to be
walking away completely empty-handed
and one of you is going to be walking
away with 20 000 pounds cash prize no
strings attached
we've got eyes on the prize we do what
we need to do it's not personal you're
gonna fight your corner
[Music]
to do it this is the plans just rubbish
throughout it doesn't make any sense I
don't know what you're talking about
sorry can I have a break
you are going to be receiving the 20 000
cash
you're evicted